you're fought all year beat out scandal
after scandal got your husband to keep
his dick in his pants so that was
probably largely because of his age and
finally reach the big night where you're
officially nominated as the Democratic
presidential candidate what better way
to celebrate than with a kick-ass video
Jack roll the kick-ass
yeah that's what I'm talking about rise
to the top and destroy all of your
haters as with most videos released on
the Internet this got a remix comedian
was the video matched up with Stone Cold
Steve Austin's theme song or the
Imperial March
yes Matt Myra yeah I mean it's gotta be
stone cold the glass shatters you're
thinking Hilary 3:16 all right
hillarie 3:16 says I don't understand
email how awesome though she smashed the
ceiling but cracked a smile